have you ever been to jail
i've been to jail five times in three
countries wow
nice do you have any mug shots probably
i don't really
seek them out what countries uh
united states new zealand and
japan don't go to jail in japan oh yeah
oh what's that
windows what were you in in japan for
oh i guess i stole a bike in the middle
of night
and i couldn't find anyone it was a
broken down bike like nobody wanted it
was already a discarded bike i swear
like i don't go around stealing bikes i
was i was lost trying to find my hotel
and like finally i'm like i'm just gonna
grab this bike and it didn't have a
light
i don't go around stealing bikes i find
them right
so then they're like they're like they
come they're like you know i guess you
have
some kind of papers or something for
your bike there i don't know what they
wanted but i didn't have it
you know it's a communication so they
got a translator and then then
they're like you stole the bike and then
uh and then
so they didn't know what to do they held
me there overnight and the next day
they're like
where did you get this bike i'm like i
don't know i don't know they're like
we're gonna drive you around until you
find it i'm like okay
and they drove me around like oh look
right there
like finally i just made up a spot i was
like that's where exactly where it was
they're like
sure i'm like right there right against
that railing that wasn't when we were
there
no this is for snowboarding i used to go
there all the time in the 90s what's the
jail like in japan
no windows just just dark dark dark like
they just open the door and check on you
every now and then like give you sushi
no i don't know they gave me some food i
didn't eat it i don't know what it was
to need it i was
just it was scary i thought i'd be in
there forever really how long were you
there for this friend
yep from the like midnight till like
midday the next day
and then what'd you do in new zealand uh
i i bought a little car this little
thing it was like a mini but
the front of it looked like a
rolls-royce so it's called a land crab a
wolseley that's cool and uh
so like i bought it and then then like i
i'd run into this little place on this
hill
and like two miles down the hill was the
bar and so i took two shots of whiskey
got in a little car drove down the hill
then i was like looking at it i was like
wow i love this little car and this cop
comes by he's like is that your little
car i'm like yeah
he's like do you just drive down that
hill i'm like yeah he's like breathe
into this
really and he gave me he gave it they
call it a instead of a dui they call it
a a d
a dickie a d i see a drunken control
a wow a drunk drunk in charge i think
i'm trying to [ __ ] that sounds right
a drunken charge of a vehicle or
something and then so i had to go to
court and it was a 500
fine and i lost my license in new
zealand for six months
i just kept driving well how long are
you in new zealand for
like four or five months and that was
for snowboarding too
yeah for because they have opposite
seasons guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude